[Music]
got good hair I'm gonna complement your
hair it's going a little bit though
how's it going yeah I've been losing it
it's like I mean if I really get up in
there guys I mean it's like starting to
disappear Ashton Kutcher reveals he's
losing his hair the 40 year old the
ranch star tells Conan O'Brien his hair
lines been slowly receding since he was
25 I went and met the guy the doctor
haired guy doctor and he was like he put
me on this at this medication called
abidor I've been like holding on to hair
pretty good right but then we decided
that we're gonna have children I didn't
know what you know was it okay is it
safe to take maybe maybe I shouldn't be
on that if you're trying to have a baby
so I stopped taking the stuff about
three years ago and now I'm experiencing
the hair loss right it's like it's
starting to go luckily the father of two
seems to have things covered would you
ever go the like you know like yeah fake
hair root would you ever do that no I'm
not too bad I'm gonna do I'll just let
it go I've established myself as like a
baseball cap wearing individual Europe
but it does go you're not gonna know
that it's gone because I'm still I'm
just gonna have the ball cap on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]